[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
herzlich Willkommen zu Tatort
Deutschland in unserem heutigen Fall
wollen wir versuchen Licht ins Dunkel zu
bekommen ich bin Toni Heyer und ich bin
Mirko Kasimir hallo heute besprechen wir
mit euch einen klassischen call Case
einen Mord bei dem einem Angst und Bange
werden kann denn so wie alles gelaufen
ist kriegt man schon ein bisschen das
Gefühl das hätte auch ich sein können
unser Fall betrifft Regionen in
Niedersachsen und Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
und da ungelöst ist hofft die Polizei
noch immer auf Hinweise die zur
Aufklärung beitragen können genau dazu
am Ende mehr und außerdem packen wir
links zur Fahndung euch in die Show
Notes aber jetzt tauchen wir ins
Geschehen wir gehen zurück ins Jahr 2011
und lernen die Person kennen um die es
heute geht
am 1 Advent 2011 wird die 20-Jährige
Annika Brille in Hannover erstochen
ihre Familie beschreibt Annika als junge
Frau mit großem Herzen die sich für
schwächere einsetzt Annika arbeitet
ehrenamtlich in einem Altenheim
unterstützt ein Pflegekind in Afrika sie
hat einen großen Bekanntenkreis und
studiert Elektron und
Informationstechnik an der
Fachhochschule Hannover das familiäre
Umfeld ist etwas Besonderes annika und
ihre Mutter sind sehr christlich und
engagieren sich in einer freikirchlichen
Gemeinde annika hat zwei Geschwister und
schon eine dreijährige Tochter mit ihrem
Bruder lebt sie in einer gemeinsamen
Wohnung mitten in Hannover das Haus
gehört ihren Eltern am 27 November 2011
wird Annika Brill mit 21 Messerstichen
vor ihrer Haustür ermordet ihre Mutter
Regina h erinnert sich an den Moment als
sie vom Tod ihres Kindes erfährt ich
hatte einen Mieter aus unserem Haus eine
SMS geschickt wir sollten uns mal melden
er glaubt es wäre irgendwas mit Annika
da rief der Beamte an und sagte
sich hinsetzen sitzen sie irgendwo und
dann wusste ich es eigentlich schon dann
hat er mir gesagt dass es ihm leid tut
mir sagen zu müssen dass meine Tochter
in ihren schweren Verletzungen gestorben
ist Anwalt Matthias Waldrach vertritt
die Familie des Opfers und hat eine enge
Bindung zu dem Fall und den Angehörigen
entwickelt es wurmt ihn dass der Fall
noch offen ist also wenn wir ein Fall
offline können wenn die Krieg oder
schafft dann ist es dieser und
ausgerechnet dieser Fall ist auch nach
zehn Jahren nicht aufgeklärt und auch
Staatsanwältin Katrin surfka lässt
dieser Cold Case nicht los wir wissen
dass eine junge Frau ihr Leben verloren
hat die ihre Zukunft noch vor sich hatte
die Mutter eines kleinen Kindes zurzeit
war das ist etwas was uns als Ermittler
natürlich berührt und belastet weil es
uns gelegen ist solche Fälle lückenlos
aufzuklären
wenn man sich die Bild schlagt sein von
damals anguckt dann wird klar wie
dramatisch sich dieser Fall darstellte
Freundin hörte Annikas Todesschreie am
Handy
Polizei jagt dieses Phantom Polizei
sucht ihren Mörder bei Facebook
[Musik]
die kohlraustraße in der Annika und ihr
Bruder an einem Mehrfamilienhaus mit der
Nummer 13 Leben liegt einerseits sehr
zentral mitten in Hannover andererseits
gibt es hier nicht Großgeschäfte oder
Restaurants also Hauptbahnhof ZOB oder
Einkaufszone die sind nicht weit aber in
der kohlraustraße da wohnt man eben
einfach nur da ist sonst nicht viel los
am 27 November will Annika gegen 19 Uhr
noch mal kurz vor die Tür um an einem
Kiosk Zigaretten zu holen nachdem sie
die gekauft hat ruft sie auf dem kurzen
Rückweg eine Freundin an ihr seid in der
dunklen Straße gerade ein bisschen
unwohl sagt sie ihr sie fühle sich
beobachtet und verfolgt und tatsächlich
dauert das Telefonat nur weniger
Augenblicke bis Annika von einem Mann
überfallen wird der wie wild mit einem
Messer auf sie einsticht die Freundin
muss alles am Handy mit anhören sie hört
Annika Schreie der Mörder gibt keine
Laut von sich bei diesem Blutbad kurz
für Ihre Haustür hat Annika keine
der Täter sticht 21 mal auf sie ein und
trifft dabei zweimal das Herz es wird
nichts gestohlen auch spricht der Täter
Annika laut Zeugen nicht an Regina
Annikas Mutter die ist zum Zeitpunkt des
Überfalls gerade in Ihrem Ferienhaus in
Rumänien eigentlich wollte Annika sogar
dort mit hin aber wegen ihres Studiums
bleibt es in Hannover wir haben dann
alles eingepackt ganz schnell und sind
die ganze Nacht durchgefahren ohne Pause
und waren innerhalb von 12,5 Stunden in
Hannover und die Polizei war schon vor
der Haustür und hat unsere Koffer
hochgetragen hat uns geholfen und hat
uns dann mitgenommen aus Präsidium und
uns befragt während der Mord für die
Familie ein ungeheuriger Schock aus dem
Nichts ist hat die Polizei
vergleichsweise viele Spuren mit denen
sie arbeiten kann Folgen haben die Tat
gesehen und beobachtet wieder Mörder Weg
lief
außerdem tauchen Hinweise auf eine
Vorgeschichte auf aber dazu später mehr
erstmal kann die Kripo schon bald mit
einem Phantombild an die Öffentlichkeit
gehen und die Bevölkerung um mit Hilfe
bitten Bild Hannover schreibt damals
ermordete Arnica B 20
Polizei jagt dieses Phantom ein junger
Mann mit aller Welt gesichtet er hat die
kurzen blonden Haare nach oben gegelt
trägt eine viereckige Brille wirkt
völlig unscheinbar geradezu harmlos doch
die Polizei ist sicher dieses Phantom
ist der adventskiller Morgen ist es eine
Woche hier dass der Unbekannte ca 20 bis
30 Jahre alt ungefähr einen Meter 80
groß schlank sportlich am Abend des
ersten Advent in der kohlrauschstraße
eine junge Studentin mit mehreren
Messerstichen niedermittlte die
20-Jährige Annika B Mutter einer
dreijährigen Tochter starb eine Stunde
später im Krankenhaus
mit Plakaten und per Facebook fandet die
Polizei seit dem nach dem Killer erste
Erfolg drei Folgen meldeten sich die
kurz nach der Tat einen Mann wegrennen
sahen nach deren Aussagen wurde jetzt
das Phantombild erstellt Polizeisprecher
Stefan Wittke wir gehen davon aus dass
es den Täter darstellt und keinen
unbeteiligten man muss aber leider sagen
dieses Bild führt zu nichts weder in der
breiten Öffentlichkeit noch in Annikas
Freundeskreis gibt es irgendwelche
Beobachtungen mit denen die Polizei
arbeiten kann und das obwohl an die 500
Hinweise zu diesem Phantombild eingehen
da die Polizei zum ersten Mal in ihrer
Geschichte auch per Facebook nach
Hinweisen sucht wird sie schon bald von
Meldungen nur so überschwemmt die
Beamten kämpfen sich durch den Berg ein
Hinweisen Kreisen den realen und den
digitalen Freundeskreis der jungen Frau
ein und beschließen den nächsten sehr
umfangreichen ermittlungsschritt zu
starten die Kripo bittet insgesamt 700
Männer um einen DNA-Test 420 willigen
ein eine Speichelprobe abzugeben 280
Männer verweigern sich ist
möglicherweise einer von ihnen der Täter
bis heute haben die Ermittler darauf
keine Antwort auch fehlt ihnen die
Tatwaffe unweit der kohlrauschstraße ist
ein großes Bahngelände mit vielen
weichen und Abstellgleisen
Polizeisprecher Stefan Wittke es ist
denkbar dass die Tatwaffe ein Messer
wahrscheinlich vom Täter hier in diesem
Bereich weggeworfen wurde hier ist der
mögliche Fluchtweg nach der Tat vom
ersten Advent hier ist eine Böschung ein
Bahndamm und es dankbar dass hier die
Waffe weggeworfen wurde so viel
versprechen die Ermittlungen am Anfang
auch aussehen führen sie jedoch zu
keinem Ergebnis die heißeste Spur findet
sich im Gedächtnis von arnikas Mutter
sie erinnert sich dass ihre Tochter von
einer Männer Bekanntschaft sprach und
von einer Bedrohung Annika das musst Du
der Polizei sagen ach ich habe erst
gefragt kennst du den wer ist das denn
das wollte ich natürlich erstmal wissen
und da hat sie gesagt den kennst du
nicht habe ich gesagt wie den kenne ich
nicht wo kommt der denn her und ich habe
dauernd versucht irgendwie ein
Zusammenhang herzustellen dass ich das
verstehen konnte weil das für mich so
überfordert war ja und dann hat sie mir
das aber nicht verraten sie hat erst
seit Jahren kommt aus dem neuen
Bundesländern und dann habe ich
natürlich die drängelt und dann hat sie
mir den Ort auch noch gesagt dann habe
ich gesagt du musst das unbedingt der
Polizei sein es geht sogar noch weiter
laut der Mutter gab es sogar einen
Zeitbezug bei dieser Bedrohung beim
Gehen hatte Annika dann besser gesagt
ach Mama ich muss ja noch was sagen da
gibt's einen Mann der will mich
umbringen und das war jetzt auch so ein
bisschen typisch für meine Tochter
völlig ohne irgendein Kontext dabei zu
haben Haut die solche Sachen raus und
ich habe gesagt wie da will ich jemand
umbringen ja der hat gesagt ich komme im
November und dann hole ich dich
bekanntlich ging Annika nicht zur
Polizei nach ihrer Ermordung lässt sich
aus den Gesprächen unter Erinnerungen
immerhin rekonstruieren dass der
bedrohliche unbekannte Mann wohl aus dem
Raum Rostock stammen soll es liegt also
nahe dass sich der Mörder unter anikas
Facebook Kontakten finden könnte nimmt
man es mit dem Phantombild zusammen dann
müsste man dort nach einem jungen
blonden Mann mit Brille und vielleicht
geh Frisur suchen der eben aus
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern stammt die
Polizei sucht auch so findet aber nichts
Anwalt Waldraff will diese Spur aber
weiter verfolgen aufgrund der Vielzahl
auch von Facebook Spuren sozusagen der
Menschen die mit Annika B in Kontakt
standen gibt es eine solche Unmenge von
einzelnen Spuren ansetzen das natürlich
die Möglichkeit besteht dass da
irgendwann auch mal was durchgerutscht
ist und das arbeite ich gerade akribisch
nach dauert und Mord verjährt hier nicht
bei uns da sollte sich kein Täter sicher
fühlen
bald jetzt sich der Mord an Annika zum
12 mal und bis heute läuft ihr Mörder
wahrscheinlich immer noch frei herum
Anwalt Wallraff bedauert dass die Kripo
den Fall noch immer nicht lösen konnte
aber er sieht keine Versäumnisse seitens
der Ermittler den kriminalbeamtinnen und
Beamten ist im Fall annikaweg kein
Vorwurf zu machen sie haben innerhalb
Hannovers außerhalb Hannovers bundesweit
alle Maßnahmen getroffenen
Ermittlungsmaßnahmen realisiert bleibt
der Appell von Staatsanwältin Katrin
sevka wenn jemand rund um die
Geschehnisse vom 27 November 2001 in der
kohlraustraße in Hannover an etwas
erinnert wenn jemand dort etwas
beobachtet hat wenn jemand sich an
bekannte erinnert die sich in diesem
Zusammenhang merkwürdig benommen haben
dann möge er oder sie sich melden auch
heute noch mehr als 11 Jahre danach
jeder Hinweis auch wenn er nach Jahren
noch kommt weil sich plötzlich jemand
durch diese Berichterstattung wieder an
den Fall erinnert oder sagt da habe ich
doch irgendwie in der Erinnerung noch
jemanden der hatte doch mal zu Annika
irgendeine Beziehung oder hat mal etwas
verlauten lassen alles was so aus der
Erinnerung herausgekramt wird wäre für
uns wichtig und könnte uns bei unseren
weiteren Ermittlungen helfen
versteht ihr jetzt so ein bisschen was
ich am Anfang meinte also du stehst
mitten im Leben du hast viele Kontakte
im realen Leben aber auch eben auf
Social Media vielleicht bedroht dich
auch mal jemand aber du nimmst das halt
nicht ernst und dann passiert ein Mord
das ist wirklich gruselig zumal der
Täter das ja sozusagen angekündigt hatte
und ich kann absolut verstehen dass
Annika nicht den Ernst der Lage
verstanden hat ich wünsche Annikas
Familie wirklich von Herzen dass der
Täter noch gefasst wird
und damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Ausgabe von Tatort Deutschland
wir danken euch fürs zuhören und freuen
uns wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal
wieder mit dabei seid die Infos zur
Fahndung nach Annikas Mörder findet ihr
in den Schorndorf bis zum nächsten mal
euer Mirko und eure Toni